openly misled the public on what was
really going on I mean again so many so
many examples on vaccine safety on
pregnant women should be getting this
six months old should should be getting
this it's safe and effective when we
neither know about safety nor long-term
Effectiveness there wasn't even an
approach that many European countries
took of let's really focus on high-risk
groups and arguably you know give it to
them where we see most amount of benefit
everyone else um you know here's what we
know here's what we don't know you know
the initial trials say that the covid
vaccines reduce symptomatic infection
for the first few months we don't know
about longterm you know we didn't test
mortality so we we can't really tell
long term on severe covid although there
was some data afterwards that seemed to
have suggested that but we don't know
about safety we're not really sure and
and and this actually goes now we can
kind of say into some of the recent news
of like people recently who kind of
bought this mainstream information on Co
uncritically and understandably fell
victim to some of the stuff and now have
recently come out and said oh that was a
mistake there's a number of examples a
lot of people know about this uh Megan
Kelly recently saying she went to her
doctor and got tested positive for for
some kind of autoimmune issue now she
was vague about it so I don't know what
the details are but she asked her doctor
about could this be related to the
vaccine because there is certainly a
link between Co the Mna vaccines and
certain autoimmune conditions and the
doctor said something like yes it could
definitely be possible a lot of people
with the vaccine have been getting this
now obviously we don't know for sure it
could be totally unrelated but you know
Megan said at the time um in this recent
interview that she basically regrets
getting the vaccine at the time um and
not making a smarter decision same thing
with v ramasami a republican uh
candidate for the presidency um talking
about how he got the the first two shots
and regrets taking it in light of what
we know about the myocarditis risk which
is concentrated in younger males and he
happens to be I believe in his late
30s uh and then Elon Musk recently
saying that his third booster shot
almost landed him in the hospital right
and and I believe he also talked Elon
about how I believe um some family
relative their son who I believe is an
adolescent male got myocarditis after
the vaccine tons and tons of these
stories and and this relates to I'll
just say one last thing to a recent
piece that I did with Dr Anish Koka in
Philadelphia he runs a leading
Cardiology clinic and his Clinic
administered the MRNA vaccines in in big
numbers mostly to elderly uh people
mostly people over 60 65 but some people
under the age of 20 and 30 some younger
people involved and I I spoke to him and
he's been very honest on this topic he
himself is double vaxed and boosted as
well as his wife and one of his
daughters I believe is imuno compromised
so he was very worried about covid not
at all a conspiracy theorist very
reasonable smart guy provacy in
generally he told me upfront he said in
light of all this information that's
come out on the myocarditis front I
regret I seriously regret giving this
vaccine especially to younger people and
violating their informed consent when at
that
time we did not know about safety and
efficacy the way we know certain things
now right at that time I was wrong to
give this out knowing that these people
were at very low risk you know may not
have had comorbidities or were IM me no
compromis and I gave it to them without
being absolutely certain about the
safety profile and that that to me is a
level of honesty whether it's Megan
Kelly Elon M but this in particular Dr
Nish Koka saying that he would have done
differently if he could you know change
his decision now that that is what you
call epistemic humility right I was
wrong at the time and now my views have
changed and now I'm going to look at the
world differently here is how my
narrative has changed here is how the
system in which I use to uh understand
reality and and analyze data has changed
and a human I get things wrong we all
get things wrong so here's how I'm going
to act differently not this other
frankly of like oh at that time
I was actually right because that's what
the data said now things have changed
but I was right at the time and I was
right and I was appropriately worried
along every step of the way because
that's what the FDA and the CDC and Eric
toel were saying therefore I was right
at the time it's like no no ow up to at
that time you being wrong about some
very serious things and that's okay to
be wrong because we're humans and we get
things wrong all the time wrong and one
of the things that they were wrong about
was the reliability of the messaging
that was supposedly derived from the
data which we now know it was wrong
because we have better information
but you know uh the the Megan Kelly
situation
um is interesting for me you you
probably do not know but I remember
vividly that Megan Kelly had me on her
show and she took me to task for a tweet
that I had made and I had already
corrected it I had deleted it reposted
it and explained that I had made an
error in my tweet but that the theme of
the Tweet was still one that I believed
in my claim in the Tweet was that
virtually everybody that I had talked to
who had gotten the
vaccines had a story to tell about a
reaction and that a lot of this was
frightening it turned out there were a
few people that I had forgotten that I
had talked to so it wasn't quite as
Extreme as I had said but nonetheless I
did have an incredible number of
conversations with people who did not
volunteer that they had had a adverse uh
reaction until I asked them at which
point I found out so my point had been
yeah you have to ask in order to know
how common these adverse reactions are
and when you do you'll find out they're
very very common in any case Megan Kelly
gave me a hard time over this I thought
she was fair about it but uh it was a it
was a difficult interview and then
there's a question about well how much
of a coincidence is it that years down
the road she herself is now reporting a
severe adverse event and I I can't you
know obviously any individual case could
be a coincidence but the fact is I also
other people that I have Tangled with
over the safety of these vaccines also
have people in their immediate Circle
who have had very serious Adverse Events
yes and so in any case the the real
point is the number of Adverse Events
here is truly staggering it is truly
staggering such that it uh if we look
around our Circle and evaluate honestly
it is touching all of
[Music]
us